hello and welcome back an incredible
story now a man called jimmy amissiel
was on holiday in his hometown in haiti
when his life changed forever
while he was on his way to visit an
orphanage
he regularly volunteered at he came
across a large group of people who were
huddled around a dustbin that's when he
found a baby in the bin now jimmy took
it upon himself to take that baby home
with him and jimmy i'm pleased to say
joins us now live jimmy just incredible
that you decided to do this thanks so
much for being with us just tell us
expand on that story that i just told
how did you come to meet uh emilio
first of all i want to say uh thank you
thanks for having me thanks for giving
me this golden opportunity to share my
story
and it's a pleasure to be here
um
on
2017 uh
i went back to haiti uh to give back to
the community and also to see my family
uh on new year's eve
was uh on my way to the orphanage to be
having a party uh for the kids uh
that evening
i heard a commotion i had people making
a noise and i thought they were just
having fun because it was going to be
the new here um
i saw a lady i saw a lady a panic lady
and i said what's going on over there
and
she was like oh they left
a baby abandoned in the trash over there
and when she told me that and i was
shocked and
i couldn't believe it i was being put
into curiosity and i'm like i need to
see what was going on and when i got a
closer look
uh
i saw a baby
lied on the pile of trash and there were
about 15 to 20 people they were just
staring at the baby
um
he was so sad to see and um
all they were saying were oh i'm not
gonna touch the baby the baby is cursed
uh
if i touch the baby something was gonna
happen to me or something like that and
um to me uh they were seeing a cursed
baby but me i saw a precious living soul
um
when i tried to pick up the baby and
people were like no don't do it jimmy
it's like you out of your mind
and at the moment it's like something
told me that you're gonna wish you that
baby and he was crying i could feel the
excruciating pain that he was feeling at
that moment and to me
he was crying in his voice like we hear
him saying save me save me save me do
something for me so
that's when i pick up the baby uh people
were shocked and they thought something
was gonna happen to me and i took the
babiano and i went to my mom's house
with it
and jimmy what where are the babies
parents has that ever been worked out
okay so when i uh uh rescued him and i
went uh went to my mom's house with him
and um we claimed him because he had
fire uh and uh allergic bites on him uh
and then after that i had to call the
police and also a george to come to
investigate so no mother or father to be
found
well and what did the police say then
and did the baby then with the police
say the baby could go into your custody
in your family's custody
oh okay this is uh that's what happened
so um
uh after they investigated the case and
um
the judge uh they know the situation in
haiti there are a lot of kids and uh
that are on the street and with no
parents and things like that and then
they were telling me that i can see your
heart
for uh kids and children uh would you
like uh to be his legal guardian
by the time that we are still
investigating on the case and so we know
that the baby is going to be well taken
care of so that's what they told me
we're seeing pictures of emilia as a
baby and also as a young boy's ways
it's very cute so what's what's
happening now you're attempting to adopt
emilia as well right oh yes that's
correct so right now under i'm in the
process of adopting him so
uh it's just that to me yes they give me
the chance to be his legal guardian and
then they say that after a couple years
if anybody uh comes to uh uh say that oh
the baby is mine but i think
you will be able to adopt him and that's
why right now i would like to uh adopt a
video and make it making my my son i
would love for him to have someone that
he can call his dad and i would be so
powerful to call him my son too
that's a beautiful thing uh jimmy uh
i hope the the adoption goes through and
how is emilia now i mean have you
thought about what you might tell him in
the future about
how you met how you came to be his
father
uh but for right now i don't know uh how
i'm gonna be able to tell him that but
somehow he's gonna know that um
someone uh
ignored parents uh have uh
left him somewhere and now is in the
good hands so
i think i'm gonna try to tell him that
in a way that it doesn't really affect
him
yeah well i hope so and of course i mean
people will be thinking that perhaps
unfortunately this might be a sign of
the poverty that haiti's facing right
now with you know a failure of
government no government no functioning
government
you go back to the iron regularly you
say you you volunteer this orphanage
like what is it like for people living
daily life in haiti right now
oh right now it's not uh it's really
difficult right now in haiti uh due to
uh political instability uh even me i
couldn't really go back for uh about
three years because uh instability there
are gangs and uh violence over there and
um yeah it's really hard to be uh in
haiti right now so and as i always uh
go back to uh
serving the office i couldn't really go
by you know the kids uh really miss me
and i really miss them too uh because uh
every uh summer and christmas time i
always go back to uh
be having really uh some uh fun and cool
times with them so i can't really go
back right now
and jimmy finally then you're trying to
raise some funds to be able to pay for
the process to adopt uh emilia and you
set up a gofundme page right
yes yes sir so um i have a gofundme page
uh if you guys would like to uh uh
support me on this journey uh i have it
on my facebook account uh isaac wait in
here uh jimmy amisial um
yes that's where you guys can find me
you can find me also on instagram so um
i'm pretty much almost meet the goal uh
if you guys would like to uh
show some love and support to that i
would be uh really uh i really
appreciate it
okay i'm sure people will you've shown
plenty of love and support jimmy uh
taking on emilia i wish you all the best
give emilio i love and uh take care
thank you jimmy
okay thank you so very much it was a
pleasure thanks for having me